Let's talk a little bit about the fact that
we still have a 100 year global pandemic going
on in the United States and many states are
improving, while many states are worsening
in terms of the spread.
We will see what effect the protests have
on spread of the virus.
It will take about 10 days to know.
Sure.
But I wanted to let you guys know something
that maybe won't will not surprise some of
you, which is that Dr. Anthony Foushee has
now confirmed that Donald Trump no longer
speaks to him very much and that he doesn't
speak to really any of the doctors on the
Corona virus task force.
Now, why wouldn't this surprise you?
Well, if you know Trump, it wouldn't surprise
you.
But five or six weeks ago, I came to you and
I said Donald Trump is now transitioning to
we are no longer going to talk about Corona
virus as a medical event.
We are no longer talking about corona virus
is a medical problem.
We're going to shift to we being Trump.
We're going to shift to roundtables with CEOs
about how much we're reopening and how many
loans we've disbursed and yada, yada, yada.
Dr. Anthony Foushee on the Corona Virus Task
Force is the top infectious disease doctor
in the United States.
And we as a country started to see less and
less of him weeks ago.
Dr. Foushee now has done a number of interviews
recently, and in one interview with STATT
News said something incredibly revealing,
but not altogether shocking.
Dr. Foushee was asked, does the president
talk to you about the vaccine work?
Often, in fact, his answer was no.
We used to have task force meetings every
single day, including Saturday and Sunday.
And about 75 percent of the time after the
task force meeting, we would meet with the
president.
So I was meeting with him four times a week
back, a month or so ago.
But as you probably noticed, that the task
force meetings have not occurred as often
lately.
And certainly my meetings with the president
have been dramatically decreased.
Now there are going to be right wingers and
Trampas who say this makes sense, this makes
sense.
The problem is going away.
The problem being corona virus.
So, of course, you have fewer meetings.
The problem is that that's not based in reality.
Look at the trend lines.
In the United States, cases and deaths have
slowly declined over a 10 week period.
But we are often still finding 20000, 22000
new cases in a single day.
In terms of deaths, fortunately, the trend
line is down, but we still regularly have
fifteen hundred deaths in a single day from
Corona virus.
So nothing is over.
This may end up merely being a warmup for
wave two in the fall, which could be even
worse.
It could be not as bad.
We don't know.
We might not really even have a break between
the two waves.
And indeed, it seemed like the breaking point
for Donald Trump was that just disastrous,
shameful press briefing in April where Trump
wondered aloud about injecting bleach and
rubbing alcohol into the body and the corona
virus.
Press briefings were already starting to wane
then, and now it's over.
And Dr. Foushee has barely any contact with
Donald Trump.
Now, there's some aspect of if I don't look
at it, if I don't talk about it, it doesn't
exist.
That's like a hear no evil, see no evil sort
of thing there.
This is kind of a weird direction to go.
But there's something called object permanence
and child development.
People will know about this already.
And this is a big milestone for little kids
as babies develop.
There is a phase where if you take a ball
and you hide it, the baby doesn't know that
the ball continues to exist.
Even if you've hidden it behind your back.
And at some point, I can't believe this is
how we're analyzing a president at some point
in child development.
Developing children realize even if I can
no longer see the ball, the ball still exists.
They can hold the idea of the ball in their
mind.
And they continue to understand that just
because you don't see the ball doesn't mean
it has disappeared from existence.
Trump's strategy is like that of a baby predevelopment
of object permanence.
I won't talk about it.
I won't look at it.
It's like it doesn't exist.
And Trump had this idea pretty early on.
Remember, with testing, Trump knew early on.
If we do more testing, we're gonna find more
cases.
Let's keep our case numbers low.
By not doing a lot of testing.
That, of course, backfired.
So then we get to a separate question, which
is, does Trump even believe experts who come
to him with information that he admittedly
doesn't even want to be given?
Not really.
Donald Trump believes he knows more than his
generals and his doctors and more than anybody.
So the benefit to meeting with the experts
is limited by the fact that Trump thinks he
knows more than them anyway.
But regardless, Dr. Anthony Foushee no longer
getting much face time with Donald Trump.
Not a big surprise.
I would love it if Dr. Foushee did regular
briefings himself.
I wouldn't even be opposed to the CDC being
part of them, like Dr. Redfield.
I know he's kind of a Trump tool.
But without Trump hovering in the background,
hinge forward at the hips and swiveling, as
he often does during during the briefings
up.
I think Dr. Foushee and Dr. Redfield together
could give us a lot of really valuable information.
Berk's, you know, remains a question mark
in terms of her just blind loyalty to Donald
Trump.
But it would be great to do it like other
countries do it.
Get the politicians out.
Let's get a briefing from medical experts.
Period.
We're not getting that either, unfortunately.
Follow The David Pakman Show on Instagram
at David Pakman show for continued coverage
of all of today's stories.
And while you are there, follow my personal
Instagram, not very political.
Many elements of recreation and gardening
on my personal Instagram may be a good respite
from consistently horrible news that we are
facing today.
I am.